[Music]
what generations this peaceful island
has been home to our family wonder if a
great danger is coming legend tells of a
hero who journey to find the demigod
Maui and together
they must save us all
No
[Music]
[Music]
semi-god of the wind and sheep i heroic
men what it's actually Maui shapeshifter
demigod of the women see hero of men I
interrupt it from the top hero of men go
impact going on a mission with some
little girls is my canoe and you will
journey to different did not see that
coming the ocean is a friend of mine
first we've got to go through a whole
ocean of bad caca hora
kako what
they're kind of cute
got your back it's Maori time
oh really
blow dart and my butt cheek we're going
to the realm of monsters don't worry
it's a lot farther down than it looks
[Music]
in the beginning there was only motion
Maui shapeshifter demigod of the wind
and sea
let's save the world I'm not going on a
mission with some kid you'd be a hero
that's what you're all about right we've
got to go through a whole ocean of bad
ever defeat a lava monster no have you
again talk to the back it's Mary Todd
stylish and showed me for a reason
come on
Stormy's up around
I am
or at the shot
do you know who Maui is only the
greatest demigod it all the Pacific
Islands with his magical visual he
slowed down the Sun pulled islands under
the sea battle monsters and I should
know
I'm Maui hey let me do this please
[Music]
nothing really what's a demigod
stormy some our elders
Oh
there Molly
[Music]
I have meant to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Melinda jiske me Roy
Erika Nava garper income-producing
Modell's Maui Jim
Salva todos nós não é transport Oh
Shelly feels dark with what you can do
yo gossage Maui transport for semi deals
David wha hello I the movie get mais uma
vez la la la the moon yo somos una de
moto navigate Oceanos how far an idea
procedure Judith uh no - [ __ ] yes kiyah
super Earths was I think a cup of bull
listen up certaPro the percent opposed
Gomora some
gopis sorry Oh Nasser stone abou
shishito to mood Oh Polly meets for you
Molina oh my driving to eat us cooking's
Kusum in the cinemas a special sneak
peek at Disney's Moana this Sunday
during Olympics coverage on NBC
Oh
[Music]
door
[Music]
Taco Bell
my
Oh
[Music]
it's now a time
the ocean is a friend of mine Disney
swim one
[Music]
you
Oh Bruce Wayne lives in Batman's attic
Wow
forget it costume don't touch that the
Maria she know what is culturally
insistent I terror really think of this